hey guys dr. Berg here I want to talk about
second skin collagen in digestion there's many
different aspects of collagen I'm going to talk
about the digestive angle first of all what is
collagen collagen comes from the Latin word which
means glue it's the stuff that holds everything
together and yes your hair is made of collagen
your nails your skin your muscles but there's
a lot of fascia which is connective tissue around
the organs around the muscles that hold everything
in and protect everything nice and tight you know
even keeps the muscles separated the tendons the
ligaments the arteries are made from collagen
your eyes have collagen the fluid inside the
eyes are have a lot of collagen your blood cells
have collagen 65% of your bodies collagen but
here's what I'm finding out with a lot of people
they're they're getting older and their collagen
is kind of falling apart prematurely and that
is because I found an interesting connection
between the digestion see when you actually eat
collagen or eat protein your body supposed to
turn the protein into collagen but it takes a
really acidic stomach to convert that process
so normally your stomach should be between one and
three the pH being really really acid neutral is
7 when you go lower it's acid you need like 1
2 3 so what's interesting is that when you're
20 years old you have a certain amount of acid
in your stomach okay as you age 30 40 50 60 70
s look what happens the pH of your stomach goes
down and down and you lose the stomach acids so
when you're aged between 60 and 70 you basically
have 25% of the acid that you had when you're
20 now this is a huge connection that no one's
talking about because if you can't digest that
collagen the tissues become rigid you lose
like elasticity you get high blood pressure
everything start sagging inside and out so so
that's interesting so what happens the pH in the
stomach is the thing that triggers the enzymes
the protein enzymes very powerful to be able
to break down the food turn it into collagen so
here's what I would recommend you do if you have
any type of collagen issues and digestive issues
fix the digestion because then you'll start to
absorb it versus trying to consume collagen from
some you know powder because you're not going to
digest it anyway fix the digestion and then see
if you can't pull it in from the food there's
many different collagen products out there and
there's I'll do a video on that but the point
is that if your stomach is not good you're not
going to pull it in outside the vinegar with
each meal very very important take some acidifier
betaine how to chloride there's different things
you can take the eat your stomach acid the other
thing is if your pH is too alkaline you have to
realize it's going to take a little time to build
that back up it's not a matter of just drinking
one glass of diluted episode of vinegar and then
everything's fine it's going to take months and
months to build it up because your pH is taken
a long time to disappear to the point where you
don't have that acidifies anymore in summary
if your digestion is not good focus on that and
you're going to see some great changes thanks for
watching hey guys thank you so much for watching
I really appreciate it please click the share
button below and I will see you in the next video